esta vez vamos a comparar 5 sextos y 5
octavos y vamos a pensar un poco en lo
que significa bien 5 sextos significa
tener cinco partes o cinco pedazos de
seis secciones si tienes un entero
imagina no sé un pastel entero y lo
cortas en seis secciones cinco sextos
es lo mismo que tomar cinco pedazos de
esas seis secciones
ahora bien cinco octavos de nuevo es
cinco pedazos o cinco partes en este
caso es lo mismo porque tomaremos cinco
de ellos pero esta vez vamos a partir el
pastel en ocho secciones es cinco
pedazos de ocho secciones y bueno
podemos dibujarlo y así representarlo
para que sea mucho más claro lo que
estoy diciendo imagina que por aquí
tenemos el pastel lo voy a dibujar más o
menos así y
para que sea el mismo pastel déjame
atraparlo lo voy a copiar y lo voy a
pegar y voy a poner el mismo pastel de
este lado así vamos a comparar 5 sextos
y 5 octavos en este primer entero voy a
poner 5 sextos y en este segundo entero
voy a poner 5 octavos así que empecemos
con 5 sextos y si seguimos pensando esto
como un pastel lo que voy a hacer es
dividir al pastel en seis secciones
entonces primero vamos a dividir al
pastel en tres secciones 1 2 y 3 y
después voy a dividir a este entero a la
mitad y así vamos a tener seis pedazos
iguales seis secciones iguales y bueno
si tomamos cinco partes o cinco pedazos
de estas seis secciones me va a quedar
lo siguiente
de ellas
y 5 aquí me estoy tomando cinco pedazos
o cinco partes de estas seis secciones
esta imagen representa cinco sextos
ahora para visualizar cinco octavos
vamos a pensar lo primero por un segundo
las piezas o pedazos en cinco octavos
serán más grandes iguales o menores que
en cinco sextos
es decir los octavos son más grandes
iguales o menores que los sextos bueno
podemos dibujarlo y ver que si tenemos
el mismo entero este de aquí ahora lo
vamos a dividir en ocho secciones y para
eso primero voy a dividir a este entero
a la mitad y después cada una de estas
mitades las voy a dividir a la mitad una
mitad
otra mitad aquí ya tenemos cuartos y
ahora voy a dividir todo esto a la mitad
de manera horizontal para que tengamos
octavos y observa se ve claro que cada
uno de estos pedazos que es de casi un
octavo es más pequeño que los pedazos de
los sextos y esto es porque tenemos que
dividir el pastel entre 8 personas
entonces nos tocaran pedazos más
pequeños bien de nuevo vamos a sombrear
5 de ellos 12
4 y 5 aquí tengo cinco pedazos de ocho
secciones y por lo tanto esta imagen
representa cinco octavos y ahora
claramente podemos ver que cinco sextos
tiene más espacio que cinco octavos toma
más área que cinco octavos una cantidad
más grande y la razón es porque cada
pedazo de éstos que equivale a un sexto
es más grande que estos pedazos que
equivalen a un octavo entonces cinco
pedazos más grandes serán mayores que
cinco pedazos pequeños o dicho de otra
manera puedo decir que cinco sextos es
mayor que cinco octavos y recuerda en
este símbolo el lado más grande o más
bien el lado abierto debe estar
apuntando al número más
entonces 5 sextos es mayor que 5 octavos
éste es el símbolo de mayor que bien voy
a quitar este ejercicio y vamos a hacer
uno más que es justo este que tengo aquí
vamos a comparar ahora dos quintos y dos
tercios pero esta vez vamos a intentar
resolverlo sin dibujar nada es decir
vamos a pensar qué significa eso es muy
importante dos quintos significa
tomarnos dos pedazos de cinco secciones
así que si tenemos un entero y lo
dividimos en cinco secciones y tomamos
dos de ellas eso serían dos quintos y
dos tercios significa dividir ese mismo
entero en tres secciones iguales y
después tomar dos de esas
ahora bien cuáles dos pedazos son más
grandes los pedazos de dos quintos o los
pedazos de dos tercios
bueno pues los dos tercios son más
grandes porque como sólo tenemos que
dividir al pastel en tres entonces
tenemos pedazos más grandes y eso lo
podemos escribir así dos quintos es
menor que dos tercios son más pequeños
tienen pedazos más pequeños entonces
estos dos pedazos son menores que estos
otros dos pedazos más grandes y de nuevo
la parte más abierta de este símbolo
señala al número más grande es por eso
que estos elementos dos quintos es menor
que dos tercios éste es el símbolo de
menor qué